or square is no longer just to check an
app to tell your friends where you've
been thank you very much more than 90
million places worldwide are mapped on
the company's servers the consumer app
has involved into a location
intelligence company so that means it
provides location data to more than
100,000 tech companies like Twitter and
Apple Foursquare's revenue grew by 74%
last year after breaking into big data
Jeff Glueck is his name we was hired in
2014 to be Foursquare's chief operating
officer he became the CEO in January of
last year welcome to you Jeff they call
you the turnaround doctor and so far it
seems to be working because people are
talking about Foursquare exactly how it
works and the changes you may need well
thanks for having me and we're really a
location intelligence company so we it
means well sure well it means that we
start with our consumer apps about 50
million people around the world use
Foursquare's apps and website to
discover great places when they're
traveling find that killer ramen spot in
Tokyo or great fish tacos in San Diego
they also log where they go checking in
on Foursquare swarm app so they can
remember that wonderful spot the spicy
bon meat sandwich they found in the
lower Eastside and remember their travel
so through that we map the world and so
we create maps of the world that let
advertisers 50 of the biggest
advertisers of the top 100 use our
services to find the kind of people with
the lifestyles that would be entering
their products we also power a hundred
thousand tech companies we help Apple
and Twitter and Samsung and snapchat
make better geo features around the
world and we also do analytics so a lot
of leading retailers and hedge funds use
our aggregate anonymous data to know
who's up and who's down in the business
world 92% of spending is still offline
yeah the predictions you've made have
been very interesting you predicted
something would happen with Chipotle
that was right that turned out to be
correct and just this week your predict
you said that tourism is down in the
United States and you know that why so
from our 50 million users around the
world about 13 million have opted in to
our research opted into the research
panel and that lets us understand how
travelers are moving between countries
and so we've seen from October to March
the US share of leisure tourism activity
globally is down about 11
so there are many reasons the currency
the dollar is up a little bit but a lot
of folks are saying that that steep
decline may be related to policies that
make the u.s. seem less attractive as a
tourism destination and we particularly
saw that from the Middle East and Latin
America fewer fewer vacationers coming
to the States
so you predicted that Chipotle's profits
would fall did you tell Chipotle that or
did you publish it at the time so we
went on TV two weeks before their
earnings and said we predict that
Chipotle sales will be down about 30
percent year-over-year two weeks later
they came out with their number was down
twenty nine point seven so we were you
know pretty close anybody that you can
predict this morning whose profits may
be down based on numbers that you're
seeing you know we're doing a lot of
interesting analysis lately one of the
studies we did is about the legalization
of marijuana what does that do to liquor
sales a lot of folks were wondering so
there are four states that have
legalized cannabis we look took a look
at Oregon which was has legalized for
over a year now and the question was
would people you know frequent liquor
stores less we did see a drop in growth
for liquor stores but interestingly
enough bars and nightclubs held
completely steady so people might
Netflix and chill with cannabis instead
of alcohol but they still want real
human contact and they're still going
out well what you yeah continued success
really interest I want to know what
you're saying about morning TV shows but
we'll talk about that later on thanks
happy to come back yes thing Jeff